sais que c'est juste de la
neige et après avoir tourné dans
cette direction pendant environ une minute, nous faisons un
autre plan en direction de la droite vers
ces collines qui  euh, 15h00,
direction,
nous allons assez lentement ouais c'est bien ouais
ouais dis-moi juste si je ne le suis pas
ouais 700 hélicoptère deux Tango
Juliette pourrait bien se coucher sur ce
peu de soleil
ici
pour
d'
accord, tu peux arrêter ça va  dans ouais,
encore 10 secondes
[Applaudissements]
secondes,
700 euh hélicoptère 2 Tango
Juliet, deux Tango Juliet 700, allez-
y, je veux juste vous faire savoir que
les opérations sont
normales,
deux Tango Juliet, vous êtes très faible, pouvez-
vous essayer une fois de plus,
ouais, deux Tango Juliet  les opérations
sont
normales copiez vos opérations sont normales
à
donnez-en
une autre il y en a une autre
à gauche ouais c'est un peu perdu dans
le sol je suppose que tu
t'arrêtes
ok
ouais oui je suis
là et j'arrive à m'incliner en faisant le
tour à droite à droite  un peu
ok je garde le euh ouais et j'en
sors la route
ouais cette équipe fait assez attention à ce que
Morning
Light ah Le la droite n'a pas d'importance
garde le tir personne ne le voit sauf
nous nous ferons une autre passe après
dis-moi  si ces buffles commencent à bouger
sans bouger, ils n'ont pas bougé
leur HS du
sol, ont le haard droit ouais, d'accord,
copie du sol Le
jardinier à Lava Creek à 8h30 a
également annoncé que nous avions une équipe de tournage pour celui-là, euh,
parce que c'est  nous sommes surexposés ouais ouais j'en ai
besoin
mais nous pourrons trouver Buffalo
où nous pourrons descendre plus bas et ouais, ne nous inquiétez pas
un peu pour les gens, que diriez-vous d'
ici ouais vous allez à gauche maintenant et je
m'incline  jusqu'à gauche à travers cette neige
qui est sur le sol là-bas ouais juste
devant ici ouais tout droit et j'arrive
nous sommes un peu trop haut mais
ouais va voir un peu de vapeur dans le
coin supérieur gauche
maintenant un peu de  Steam ne sait pas vraiment
où est la route
oh la lumière est mauvaise ouais je pense que la
lumière est juste passée derrière le nuage là,
c'est un peu des
nuages ​​perdus mais ça pourrait être une bonne photo du matin
peut-être que demain matin finissons-
le mais euh ouais nous allons refaire  demain
matin, j'espère qu'il n'y aura pas de
nuages, c'est drôle comme certains Buffalo
restent ensemble et certains d'entre
eux s'en fichent d'être seuls
ouais et se contentent de se remplir de
Steam sur la vapeur, ils WIP à travers le
plan dans le
ouais,
gardez  ça va comme ça et l'équipe devrait à
nouveau bien fonctionner, ok, nous pouvons descendre
ouais
TR pour trembler juste un peu ici,
c'est
ok
Vitesse 700, ok ouais, la vitesse est excellente
ouais et je suppose que je devrais juste
m'arrêter ici et ensuite je vais  Je vais
affiner un plan TI, bien, nous
le ferons deux fois, alors ouais, finissons le côté et
revenons encore et faisons une verticale avec
les arbres et puis euh,
nous ferons un cercle autour du
bison, nous le ferons.  comme quelques
plans, d'accord, je vais les laisser glisser du
bas du plan ici par le bas du cadre,
puis compter jusqu'à 15, puis nous ferons
une boucle et reviendrons faire la même
piste de vol au-dessus des arbres
ouais, allons au-dessus de la rivière  ouais, donc
nous nettoyons la rivière sur la
neige, ok, tu peux arrêter, ok, arrête d'
enregistrer